sie wollen auf und davon birgitt und
jürgen haben kinder großgezogen jetzt
ziehen sie los auf die philippinen
die familie fischer aus dem aargau
wünscht sich mehr lebensqualität
sie bricht auf in die weite kanadas von
appenzell ans mittelmeer
monika und bert daniela folgen ihren
traum sie bauen ein kleines hotel in der
türkei
[Musik]
betriebsausflug auf den mauern fluss auf
der philippinischen insel palawan birgit
und jörg sein haben ein boot gemietet
und ihre bauarbeiter zu einem fest
eingeladen wo sie sich ja so schnell
würde können deshalb ist damit punkt
gegen den bonus noch einmal bis groß
[Musik]
mitten im boot steht ein buffet mit
lokalen köstlichkeiten
[Musik]
die bootsfahrt ist auch für das er
passen eine wohlverdiente pause in einer
turbulenten zeit
in der letzten folge von auf und davon
zogen sie in ihr ressort ein
obwohl ihre warnungen noch nicht fertig
war doch birgit fühlte sich überflüssig
auf der baustelle und sie bekam
zunehmend probleme mit ihren beinen in
der türkei fehlte der beton für die
hotelterrasse die beiden auswanderer
verließen ihre baustelle und brachen zu
einer einkaufstour auf die sie bis nach
istanbul führte in kanada machte die
familie fischer einen besuch beim
arbeitgeber von vater kurt noch leben
sie im camper doch bald wollen sie ein
richtiges dach über dem kopf
die kanadischen häuser sind eindrücklich
doch nicht immer in bestem zustand
nun ist schon einiges machen
[Musik]
das fest auf dem fluss war ein voller
erfolg und hat alle begeistert
ausbauen will
[Musik]
erst wer zusammen gefeiert und gelacht
habe davon ist das ehepaar überzeugt
könne ein wirklich gutes verhältnis zu
seinen arbeitern haben
[Musik]
eine sehr willkommene abwechslung war
dieser ausflug für birgit denn trotz der
freiheit und der paradiesischen
schönheit der insel bekannt sie mühe mit
dem süßen nichtstun
in der schweiz war die ehemalige
schulleiterin gewohnt verantwortung zu
tragen und die dinge in die hand zu
nehmen
[Musik]
nein
heute weiß birgit auch unter palmen
braucht der mensch aufgaben
eine davon ist ihr täglicher spaziergang
mit der affendame mich neu und den
hunden trotz der gelegentlichen zweifel
birgit würde sich wieder für das leben
auf der insel entscheiden
[Applaus]
die zielgruppe was du ja also ich danke
für sie schon berichtet
obwohl man sich nicht immer einfach ist
aber sicher ist dass alles was eifere
sie hat immer alles gut ein fachmann
geschichte schwierig also mein gedanke
ja soll jetzt einfach wieder heiko
neumann und wo man braucht wenn man sich
netzwerk hat aber das ist jetzt
mittlerweile ganze zusammen ich kann
andere sich ein anderer wie die höhe
ich bin sicher für die spaßfaktor stand
ich unter der arbeiten veranstaltet bei
dem bingo wegen hochwassers nicht besser
kühl note für die handys und der
sinnlichen singen mit kroko und so den
clash of the board das ist auch die
minis und auch frisch
[Musik]
euro
die familie fischer liegt noch immer im
camper heute besichtigen sie erneut ein
haus ihr drittes bisher
[Musik]
vor 150 jahren suchten in diesem gebiet
kanadische gold krebber ihr glück nun
hoffen die fischers auf die erfüllung
ihrer träume
sehen sie dort den jungen platz für
pferde
wenn sie irgendwann mal pferde haben
wollen wenn sie dieses anwesen leben und
dann größere tiere
[Musik]
das haus ist riesig das parterre allein
bietet mehr wohnfläche als das
dreistöckige haus welches die fischers
in der schweiz besaßen selbst das
badezimmer ist größer als ihre alte
küche inspiziert
so ist sie doch was würde man die beiden
augen der hilfe ist maxi wien west ihre
material und da das landhaus mit 320
quadratmeter wohnfläche ist in bestem
zustand
[Musik]
der traum am waldrand wäre sofort
bezugsbereit und ist für umgerechnet 380
1000 franken zu haben
die fischers haben beste chancen den
zuschlag zu bekommen
eigentlich müssten sie nur ja sagen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in der türkei haben monika und bert an
istanbul verlassen und sind auf dem
heimweg richtung süden
[Musik]
die fähre überquert einen ausläufer des
marmarameeres dass sie einmal in die
türkei auswandern würden hätten monika
und berta nie gedacht als sie sich vor
neun jahren kennenlernten
sie hatten sich auf ein normales
familienleben eingestellt doch manchmal
wenn einem ein wünsch versagt bleibt
wagt man dafür ein anderes abenteuer
[Musik]
lieber light oder hamas grünen stabil
schließlich sei nicht gefallen das
nachsehen
und dieser traum hier eigenes hotel wird
langsam gestalt an
[Musik]
was machst du wachst du wachsende
problem und schwierig reise
[Musik]
hey
weil ihr herzensprojekt ein juwel werden
soll waren die beiden einen umweg über
die ortschaft gedacht dort gibt es
bestes porzellan zu kaufen
künftig wollen sie ihren gästen typisch
türkisches frühstück servieren
dafür brauchen sie allerlei schalen und
teller es nicht gibt
[Musik]
auf palawan blauen berge zeit wochen
immer wieder seltsame schmerzen in den
beinen
eine massage soll linderung bringen ich
weiß anderer irgendwann über muskel wo
man so schnell macht und jetzt laufen
ineinander ich heute bin immer abholen
und jetzt hat sie neben geschenken
passiert dass ich wieder normal
ich war also das ressort die masseurin
beherrscht ihr handwerk aber bei birgit
beschwerden stößt sie an grenzen
birgit passt es gar nicht nur um zu
liegen im gegensatz zu ihrer katze die
auswanderin ist voller tatendrang und
würde zu gerne endlich ihre neuen
backofen ein feuer
nach vier monaten bauzeit stehen im
ferienresort jungle beat bereits drei
bungalows und das restaurant eröffnen
wollen dieses erst wenn alle häuschen
stehen auf die luxus bungalows für
anspruchsvolle rät touristen
das gibt es erste hüsli folkloristisch
also nicht teil sondern wirklich mit
bach stärkung hat und warm und
kaltwasser also so wie man sich freuen
wenn man vor der schweiz grund ist
erhält die und davids kummer treiben
wenn dieser das mit 2000 mitarbeitern
unterhalten
seit zwei monaten leben die fischer sind
camper auf 30 quadratmetern
es ist fast ein bisschen alltag
eingekehrt um halb sechs ist tag macht
[Musik]
in der schweiz kam kurz zum mittagessen
nach hause in kanada partie man at eine
lunchbox
ich will gute naja so wie du bist
für den vater beginnt ein normaler
arbeitstag
die kinder jedoch erwartet etwas
besonderes
halloween
[Musik]
eine jener traditionen mit denen
christin und paul ihnen aufwachsen
werden
[Musik]
zu halloween kürbisse ausgehöhlt und mit
furchterregenden fratzen versehen
mit einer anderen familie die auch auf
den campingplatz wohnt hat eine bereits
freundschaft geschlossen
[Applaus]
willst du zu unserem kemper kommen dort
hat es sonne dein tisch als sie noch in
der schweiz lebten war es nicht wichtig
dass die kinder mit traditionen
aufwachsen in kanada genauso halten
das ist wahrscheinlich auswählen
natürlich
ich habe das folgen haben
[Musik]
was machst du ich schnitze einen bösen
und einen freundlichen hillary lebt mit
ehemann einem schweizer und den kindern
zeit drei jahren im camper wo immer ihr
mann arbeit findet richtet sich die
familie auf einem campingplatz ein
[Musik]
mit einer kerze bestückt und vor die
camper türe gestellt sollen die kürbisse
böse geister verjagen
[Musik]
monika im porzellanladen
die appenzellerin ist in ihrem element
[Musik]
sie hatten hier gelassen und jetzt 4
hinten
das sind e tron ich gern hätte zunächst
einmal zeigen die drei farben über die
farben sind sie sich einig über die
menge des geschirrs nicht
40-45 toll was zum schreiben war gut
dann können wir alles notieren
du kannst sowieso nicht klappt bestimmt
hätte ich mir so klar 80 80 genug hey du
musst auch fordert haben was machst du
wenn es mal kaputt weil wir nicht so
viel sagen dann heißt es was sagst du
mir über klugscheißer klugscheißer
deswegen recht herzlich und funktion ist
ja auch ein vorrat haben das ist kein
haus also sagt jetzt reform was wir
brauchen
mit dem rheinland sie kann sich immer
noch nicht entscheidend ob mit oder ohne
rand monika und wärtern sind mit leib
und seele bei der sache
schließlich geht es um ihre zukunft und
um viel geld nach einer guten stunde
haben sich die künftigen hoteliers für
den kauf von 450 geschirr teilen
entschieden
mit hunderten viel mehr fahr ich bin ich
bei einer zigarette verraucht auch per
tanz ärger schnell manchmal haben wir
wirklich stress sie erklärt was ich
erkläre etwas manchmal finden wir nicht
den richtigen weg für uns beide und dann
sind wir beide sauer gegenseitig dann
sprechen wir vielleicht eine stunde lang
nicht
aber dann geht wieder alles in ordnung
die bestellung ist aufgegeben und
bezahlt die lieferung des geschirrs
erfolgt direkt in ihr hotel
[Musik]
eigentlich herrscht pure idylle auf der
insel palawan nur einer hat ein problem
damit spielt der kopf will der
spekulationen um eine simple tatsache
der autoschlüssel ist weg einmal mehr
dabei will jörg heute nach puerto
princesa dem hauptort der insel
einkaufen gehen
[Musik]
pause
duschen
der duschkopf ist mittlerweile auf der
richtigen höhe montiert vom schlüssel
aber keine spur
[Musik]
oktober auch in provisorisch
eingerichteten schlafzimmer nichts da
kann nur noch die angestellte der sie
ihre helfen
weißt du wo mein auto schlüssel ist
bingo desiree hat ihn bereits in der
hand das ist gut
dinge wie üblich am nagel
es ist aber natürlich während jörg in
die stadt fährt kann birgit endlich
ihren ofen ein feuer heute soll ihre
erste philippinische pizza auf den tisch
kommen
ja
ein selbstkritisches grünes zweite
vorsitzende der leeds und dann wird isra
frage warum etwas für eine tonne bringen
der sport ist 4000 sommerlager frauen
und primitiver trotz der heutigen
massage birgit hat noch immer große mühe
beim gehen
jeder schritt tut weh
[Musik]
es muss friedlich
es sind nicht nur schmerzen manchmal
spürt birgit sogar ihre fußsohlen nicht
mehr
doch birgit ist tapfer und will sich
durchbeissen sie lenkt sich ab mit ihrer
leidenschaft den button
[Musik]
in kamera steht die familie fischer vor
einer rosigen zukunft sie haben das
landhaus gekauft hat ist begeistert
doch noch wohnen die fischers nicht in
der natur sondern auf dem campingplatz
deshalb unternimmt alles einen ausflug
zum zauberhaften fox mountain der talks
mountain ist der hausberg von williams
lake trotz des provisorischen lebens im
camper haben sich christin und gut
eingelebt
[Musik]
die eigenen vier wände der garten zum
austoben das wird kristin und pauli bald
noch mehr halt geben in ihrer neuen
heimat dass sie das richtige haus wie
ihr neues leben gefunden haben
daran zweifelt nicht wirklich denn wer
hält 100 prozent vorsehe huster außerdem
die personen erkennen
[Musik]
es ist mitternacht als monika und bernd
an endlichen aller charter ankommen
über 16 stunden waren sie an diesem tag
unterwegs
[Musik]
da sind wir
samstags ist in al assad dem markttag
während des sommers tummeln sich hier
unzählige feriengäste jetzt im winter
sind fast nur einheimische unterwegs zu
ihnen zählt nun auch monika die seit
vier monaten im dorf lebt per zufall
trifft sie auf ihren architekten guten
morgen wie geht's gut und er hat dann
ist auf der baustelle und ich kaufe ein
kaum ein tag vergeht an dem wörtern
nicht die baustelle besucht er und
monika haben seit ihrer auswanderung
kaum je freizeit genießen können
diese sache was wir jetzt machen kann
man nicht hinkriegen denke ich es könnte
ohne stress gehen wenn man alles zu
einem bau filme gegeben hätte und da
musst du mir auch nicht mal da seien
jetzt entweder jeden tag haben mir immer
etwas zu tun mit dem bau und alles
konzeption natürlich wir haben keine
kollegin momentan hier
wir stehen auf unserer weine wir
unterstützen gleichzeitig zusammen und
schwierigkeiten kommt auch dazu und
stress haben ja auch weil wir sind auch
menschen
werthan hatte beruflich schon
führungspositionen inne
in der hotellerie und in einem
industrieunternehmen aber einen baum
leidet er zum ersten mal und mit dem
hotel bauen er und monika ihre zukunft
alles was sie besitzen stecken die
auswanderer in dieses projekt geld und
einsatz auch sein aussehen hat mir dann
verändern
die decke kommt noch zehn zentimeter
tiefer ich weiß nicht mehr genau was wir
geplant haben lass mich noch mit meiner
frau reden
ich gebe euch dann bescheid möchtest du
irgendjemandem etwas erklären da sagst
du etwas aber die hören sich nicht zu
die machen es trotzdem so heute und dann
sagst du ich hatte doch keine bad und
deswegen hast du mir kein erde gezeigt
wenn man den bart hat hat man auch
bisschen mehr aus weil da sind wir am
baustelle
ich wollte auch hier nicht wie ein
netbook stehen bei dem ganze
mitarbeitern und die akzeptiere mich das
auch so sein
[Musik]
aus pillnitz neu im steinofen steigt
rauch
nicht nur wegen des ofens ist birgit in
bester stimmung
sie hat ihre bauarbeiter zum bingo
spielen eingeladen
wenn der gz hat sie weniger schmerzen
[Musik]
der gewinn geld zum aufladen des handys
und für sie ist und im habe und zweitens
können sie dann mit einer woche lang mit
ihren frauen telefonieren in porto 3 und
jetzt und dann stellt sich die frage wie
heißt er hoffentlich aber meine jungs
haben der so bis vor insistierte
musikwinkel spiele das ich das aus haben
die sozial- steuer- und sie hat ja aber
das ist immer so sie sind schon da
die serie hat jörg zum einkaufen
begleitet während ihrer abwesenheit
konnte birgit für einen kurzen moment in
der küche schalten und walten wie sie
wollte die restaurantküche ist
eigentlich dieses reich dass sie aber
teilen muss denn die sens haben keine
eigene küche
zehn minuten später ist es soweit jörg
darf die erste single die pizza
anschneiden
[Applaus]
die freude über ihre erste single die
pizza lassen birgit die
gesundheitsprobleme für einen kurzen
moment vergessen
[Musik]
für treue ist heute ein großer tag in
der schule feiern die kinder halloween
an halloween ist es tradition dass sich
die kinder verkleiden
für pröll ist es fasnacht auf
nordamerikanisch nun ist er der könig
der löwen
solange die familie auf dem campingplatz
wohnt bringt annett polizeischule seit
einem monat besucht der sechsjährige die
erste klasse der elementary school in
den kleinen den abschied vom mami zu
erleichtern lesen die mütter ihren
kindern zum unterrichtsbeginn eine kurze
geschichte vor aber dann gilt es ernst
die kleinen marschieren in die turnhalle
zu ihrer halloween feier
die vierjährige kristin hat sich wohl
verkleidet zum mitfeiern ist sie aber
noch zu klein
[Musik]
mit der mutter fährt sie wieder zurück
zum campingplatz heute wollen sie packen
nach zwei monaten im camper ziehen sie
endlich in ihr eigenes richtiges haus am
waldrand
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bis ihr hotel fertig ist bewohnen monika
und bert an ein kleines häuschen jetzt
den winter sorgen ein heizstrahler warme
socken und nicht zuletzt monikas
kochkünste für gemütlichkeit so schulze
ich mache halt alles war so erfolgt so
richtig die apotheke das witzig ist
ungefährt sie sich eigentlich alle
sachen managt die richtige versicherung
wenn es probleme mit der honige anarchie
immer alles gretle zum deutsche sitzt
genau umgekehrt und wenigen ist türkisch
immer noch nie sagt wichtig wer die frau
andere sachen machen also vor dem
hermann leiter hinrichs vom nachwuchs
zeigt dass mehr alles teile
doch solange sie bauen und sie vorüber
gehen die mids häuschen wohnen haben sie
eine traditionelle rollenverteilung
schmeckt fein jetzt machst die zweite
mal dem dollar und wegen schmecken haus
sind sieht es so ganz genau weiß wie die
türkischen frauen machen
ich habe noch probleme zu erklären ist
ich denke nicht so toll
und stimmt ihn mir zusammen zu wollen
[Musik]
diese kürbisse schrecken keine geister
ab sie werden verpackt damit die fischer
am nächsten tag früh morgens ins haus
einziehen können
verlassen sie noch am abend den
campingplatz das leben im camp ist
geschichte verhältnis sind heute so
riesig und er hat aber weniger mit mit
in ostafrika leiden hunger das ja dass
man platz und die warth rechnen und
sowie 3 aber es hätten hier groß klagte
schon ist das glück sie und außerdem
habe ich jetzt gerade gut können wir
jetzt abbrechen bevor der hintergrund
also ich weiß nicht wie der winterwetter
verbringen
ich glaube das wäre nicht so das wahre
für kristin und polly heißt es abschied
nehmen von ihren ersten spielkameraden
die kinder der nachbarin harry werden
auch den eisigen kanadischen winter im
camper verbringen müssen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
du kannst bei uns wäsche waschen und ein
schaumbad nehmen
[Musik]
die nächtliche fahrt führt sie am see
entlang hinauf ins alte goldgräber
gebiet zum haus am waldrand
noch steht der familie eine allerletzte
nacht im camper bevor
doch dieser steht nun im eigenen garten
[Musik]
in der nächsten folge von auf und davon
beginnen die fischers ihr traumhaus
einzurichten vater kurz verlässt die
familie für eine ganze woche
er muss ein blockhaus aufrichten
in der türkei gehen die arbeiten nur
schleppend voran
nebst verzögerungen kommt es auch zu
pannen
birgit reist in die schweiz und lässt
ihre beine ärztlich untersuchen
jörg bleibt alleine zurück trost spenden
im berg ist ihren
[Musik]
ich muss mich ja nie wieder freikommen
chinas neuen star
[Musik]